quand l'expérience sportive se met au
service de la science cela donne une
expédition inédite une expédition de
l'extrême le défi ouvrir une voie de
canyoning encore inexploré au départ du
python des neiges à 300070 mètres
d'altitude la plus importante voie de
canyon chamerréalisée en termes de
dénivelé 2370 mètres ça se passait en
octobre 2009 à l'origine de cette
première une démarche scientifique du
géologue Vincent Famin pour retracer
l'histoire de ce volcan éteint depuis
12000 ans Aymeric bocheron directeur
technique de l'expédition retrace pour
nous cette grande première dix jours à
la découverte des entrailles du plus
haut sommet de l'île
alors l'idée de Vincent Famin à
l'origine donc de réaliser une coupe
géologique d'un volcan de points chauds
de type à voyant
sachant que a priori ce serait une
première dans le monde permettrait de
prouver et peut-être de prévoir que des
volcans de poids chauds qui prennent
trop d'altitude deviennent instables et
ne demandent qu'à s'effondrée avec une
hypothèse de départ qui semble être que
le Piton des Neiges à l'origine était
beaucoup plus haut et qu'il a subi un
effondrement majeur
en fait on s'est retrouvé à descendre
l'arrondissant à 10 mètres supérieurs
2400 mètres de dénivelé
ce qui est a priori actuellement sur les
infos qu'on a prises le record du monde
de dénivelé dans l'activité et donc sa
place la Réunion une fois de plus comme
étant le spot mondial du canon la cerise
sur le gâteau qui était pas un objectif
du tout et complètement une surprise
c'était de trouver les pseudes de
takilites en haut ça c'est génial c'est
c'est le petit bonheur du géologue
complètement inattendu et c'est quelque
chose qui fait qui fait rêver du point
de vue on cherche quoi
une série de ressauts qui sont en fait
des likes c'est à dire des intrusions de
magma dans des fissures
c'est entre deux et trois sacs par
personne de 30 à 40 45 kg suivant les
sacs puisque malgré un repérage
ULM et hélicoptère pour essayer de
prévoir un petit peu ce qu'on allait
rencontrer et comment j'allais m'y
prendre le canyon est tellement étroit
qu'il y a plein de parties qui sont
invisibles et qu'on a tout intérêt à
être nombreux pour avoir plein de
matériel et
être efficace et avancer vite son temps
mort
dans ce genre de paroi le le danger
c'est que ces fracturé de partout donc
la difficulté de ce genre d'expédition
c'est d'arriver à équiper à vue de
trouver le rocher sain de créer des
lignes qui soient suffisamment correctes
pour que derrière il y ait neuf
personnes qui passent sans qu'il y ait
dans mon lit
mais bon c'était un engagement qu'on
avait pris avec le parc national de de
ne pas être traumatisant pour
l'environnement en dehors du canyon
c'est à dire que dans le canyon a priori
c'est là qu'on fait le moins de balle
par contre on n'est pas sorti sur les
côtés et l'idéal serait de refaire une
descente dans ce parcours pour pouvoir
emmener des botanices qui eux on
probablement des découvertes majeures à
faire sur le côté parce que apparemment
il y a de la végétation assez
exceptionnelle